we're going to begin this hour with
music's biggest night the grammys john
bates you heard us talking about him he
won big taking home five awards
including album of the year you go john
batisse breakout superstar olivia
rodrigo performed her huge hit driver's
license she won three grammys including
best new artist the ceremony also
included some very touching tributes
anthony mason was there catching last
night's action anthony good morning i
thought trevor noah knocked it out of
the park i thought the show was so
beautifully produced well done ben
winston
and jesse collins but for you anthony
you were there in the room what was it
like
it's everything you said gail and it was
really special and as you pointed out
especially for john batiste who had the
most wonderful reaction to winning album
of the year if he looked a little
stunned at first i think it was because
he beat out billy eilish lil nasex
olivia rodrigo dosia cat
but what a night for him five grammys
and an extraordinary performance so our
friend did really well the show started
with a smoking performance by silk sonic
bruno mars anderson pack won both song
and record of the year for their huge
hit leave the door open but as nate has
pointed out they've been playing a
residency here in vegas i went saturday
night and bts was in the audience that's
how hot a ticket it was and to echo nate
it may be the best show i have ever seen
it was also a special night for a
personal favorite joni mitchell who won
for best historical album and that was
after she was honored friday night as
music cares person of the year uh she
that's the grammy charity by the way she
joined in the finale big yellow taxi led
by brandy carlisle
this is really important it is the first
time joni mitchell has sang in public
since suffering a brain aneurysm back in
2015 that's seven years ago so really an
amazing moment she walked up on stage
and sang along if that video looked a
little sketchy it was because it was
shot by a fanboy namely me because that
event was not televised you guys
all right anthony now i want to go to
vegas you guys have sold me you got to
see the silk sonic and you guys thank
you so much well i can't wait well done
now that's anthony anthony knows his
music and has seen a ton of he's been to
a concert or two you had me on the fence
he pulled me over there you go